[laughter, applause]
ALL RIGHT.
EVERYBODY FOCUS UP. LOOK.
THIS PARTY TONIGHT
COULD BE A MODEL
FOR THE WAY THAT THE WORLD
SHOULD WORK.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY...
I'M TOTALLY STOKED
TO THE MAX ABOUT IT.
ALL RIGHT?
YOU GUYS FEELING GOOD?
OH, DENNIS, WHAT,
ARE YOU SHOOTING VIDEO?
- YEAH, MAN.
- ALL RIGHT, WELL,
BE CAREFUL WITH THAT.
I MIGHT RUN
FOR OFFICE SOMEDAY.
[laughter]
NOW, TRUST ME,
I THINK THAT THIS PARTY CAN BE
THE MOST INSPIRATIONAL PARTY
THIS CAMPUS HAS EVER SEEN.
IS THAT COMING TO ME?
LET ME JUST GRAB THAT.
THAT'S SOME RIGHTEOUS BUD.
SOME RIGHTEOUS BUD
WE GOT GOING ON THERE.
WE NEED SOME BODACIOUS
JOCK BABES COMING IN.
WE NEED SOME HOT-ASS
PUNK ROCK BABES.
I-I-I DON'T CARE
WHERE THEY COME FROM.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING--
IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE HAVE A DIVERSITY
IN THE, UH...
PUSSY DEPARTMENT.
INTERCEPTED.
DON'T SLEEP ON BARRY O.
DON'T EVER
SLEEP ON BARRY O.
WHOO!
[party noise, chatter]
- APARTHEID IS TOTALLY GNARLY.
IT'S A GNARLY INSTITUTION.
WHERE IS THE--DENNIS, DEN--
THERE WE--COME HERE.
GET THIS, GET THIS.
OKAY, WE--WE GOTTA HAVE A SYSTEM
IN PLACE TO GET EVERYBODY WEED.
ALL RIGHT? SO JUST WATCH--
THIS IS HOW YOU'RE GONNA DO IT.
ALL RIGHT, THIS--THIS IS--
I'M REALLY [bleep] FROSTY
RIGHT NOW, BY THE WAY.
THIS IS YOUR CONSTITUTION,
ALL RIGHT?
IT'S JUST A PIECE OF PAPER.
WE GOTTA KEEP ITS INTEGRITY,
'CAUSE IT'S GONNA HOLD
EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
THIS RIGHT HERE...
THIS IS US.
THIS IS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE'RE SPECIAL. WE'RE MAGIC.
WHOA, YAY, WE ALL LIVE IN HERE.
ALL RIGHT,
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS THAT WE DON'T
GET TOO FAR APART.
ME AND YOU, WE--
WE GOTTA BE CLOSE.
THAT'S--THAT'S THE MAGIC
OF AMERICA IS LOVE.
OTHERWISE, YOU'RE GONNA
GET AIR BUBBLES IN THERE.
IT'S GONNA START
CANOEING AND EVERYTHING.
WE DON'T WANT THAT,
ALL RIGHT? YOU GET THAT?
ALL RIGHT, LOOK.
I'M WAY AHEAD OF YOU, BRO.
I'M ALREADY DONE.
BOOM, FIREWORKS.
FOURTH OF JULY. THAT'S FOR YOU.
WE WANT LIKE
A TON OF THESE.
OH, MY GOD,
I'M SO [bleep] BLAZED.
I'M SO [bleep] HIGH.
OH, [bleep].
WHAT WAS I SAYING?